and he said something to john that i
can't repeat on this camera
but all of us stepped back then was like
whoa
okay okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tatum crossover pull-up jumper that's
good
tatum drives down and throws it down wow
so when we talk about jason tatum he can
score the basketball from the
three-point line he's got all the moves
he's got the handle and then he's a
great finisher around the rim and then
he has that killer instinct that when
you give it to him at the end of the
game he can make a shot he wants to make
a shot and he's not afraid of anybody
those are things that you like about
tatum that's the present day player but
now i want to introduce another guy by
the name of tom chambers that you
probably never heard of
tom chambers
6
10
unbelievable jumper leaper shoot it from
the perimeter tough now here's when we
really mess you up long blonde hair
pretty blue eyes walks out on the floor
drafted from utah i remember i'm in
detroit i'm playing with the pistons and
i'll never forget you know it's it's me
john long terry tyler we're at the foul
line and john long is really giving it
to tom chambers like you know he's
talking to him and everything and he's
telling me soft and all this other stuff
and i'm just listening to john lone go
at chambers and all of a sudden chambers
looked down at john
and he said something to john that i
can't repeat on this camera
but all of us step back then was like
whoa okay okay and tom chambers
proceeded to give it to us that was my
first kind of introduction to tom
chambers
[Applause]
what tom chambers is is known for most
by all of you young people is you see
him dunking over mark jackson and
mark is always very nice when they show
that clip of him getting dunked on or
dumped over by tom chambers and tom
chambers is up so high literally his
head is looking right at the basket and
he don't dunk it like this he dunks it
like that
welcome to the pacific northwest the
emerald city is gleaming for the 37th
annual nba all-star game his first
all-star appearance the personal forward
from the hometown seattle supersonics
tom
chambers
the 87 all-star game in seattle samson
had just did it to us in in indianapolis
so now we're saying okay ralph is hurt
and we're looking for okay who's going
to be the replacement for ralph sampson
and then they replaced samson with tom
chambers now everybody else is like okay
tom chambers i'm like oh no no no no and
now in my mind i'm like oh man we're
getting ready to see ralph sampson and
magic johnson all over again tom
chambers magic johnson put on an
unbelievable show in seattle tom
chambers ends up winning the mvp trophy
in seattle that was kind of like his
coming out party tom chambers kevin
johnson when they got together in
phoenix they were a great team great
great team
you need to know about tom chaney
[Music]
all i'm gonna say is this tom chambers
look it up very few people in our league
have scored
66
tom chambers is one of them